have done a lot of things in my life and
they said what are you most most
proudest beside my kids in it
I said the Dick Van Dyke Show I said it
that's it I can put that on my tombstone
because there's 158 shows in the first
30 or 40 episodes I wrote by myself Carl
Reiner the award-winning writer director
producer and actor known for creating
the Dick Van Dyke Show has died ET can
confirm he was 98 years old Carl died
Monday night in his Beverly Hills home
and was surrounded by his family his son
actor director Rob Reiner confirmed the
news on Tuesday morning tweeting as I
write this my heart is hurting
he was my guiding light Dick Van Dyke
took to Instagram to honor his friend
writing 100% pure mensch we love you so
much
besides what I've written I'm in the
process of getting out three or four new
books and one of them is called how to
live forever
it's a 271 page book that starts with
the line start a project work on and
improve it when you approve of will you
improve him start a new project that
line goes for 271 pages the truth of the
matter is so you have something to do
you'll stay alive even in his 90s Carl
was sharp as ever and used his platform
to bring attention to political issues
such as immigration voter registration
and speaking out against President
Donald Trump in a video posted to his
Twitter account in 2018 Carl said his
personal goal was to live until the 2020
November election November 6th we can
vote for elected officials who will hold
this president accountable and after
we've done that
my personal goal will be to stick around
until 2020 and vote to make sure we have
a decent moral law abiding citizen and
Washington will make us all proud again
to live in America over his career that
spanned more than 60 years
Carl directed dozens of films and TV
shows like Steve Martin's the jerk and
made friends with other Hollywood
legends like Mel Brooks Mary Tyler Moore
Dick Van Dyke and Betty White
but his big break came in 1959 when Carl
pitched and starred in an
autobiographical sitcom pilot called
head of the family the concept was
recast and renamed the Dick Van Dyke
Show
Carl directed and produced the show in
addition to portraying the character
Alan Brady who was born in the Bronx
studied acting in high school and landed
his first directing job while serving in
an entertainment unit of the Air Force
during World War two in 1943 Carl
married actress Estella boss'd who you
might remember from the 1989 film When
Harry Met Sally I'll have what she's
having the two shared three children
actor director Rob Reiner author Annie
Reiner and artist
Lucas Reiner the couple was married for
64 years until Estelle's death in 2008
what do you hope your legacy will be
well that I made people laugh
you